MAX SALTONSTALL: Welcome to
"BeyondCorp in a Bottle,"
where we explore
journeys into the world
of context-aware access
and zero-trust networks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You've probably got
a list of employees
living in Active Directory
or some single sign-on
or LDAP equivalent.
In order to enforce
your security policies
and take advantage of
context-aware access,
you'll need to create smarter
fine-grained controls.
Google's tools need to know
who's asking for access,
so we'll need to get
that identity information
into Google somehow.
The easy way, and what we do
at Google, is to use G Suite,
and then all your identities
already live in Google Cloud.
If you want some extra
work, though, you
can always sync your identities
from your system to Google.
Let's look at both options.
For G Suite companies,
your identity already
lives on Google Cloud,
so Google Cloud Platform
can see all the users
and groups you've set up.
Quick and easy.
If you're on Active Directory
or OpenSSO, LDAP, et cetera,
then Google's Cloud
Directory Sync Tool
lets you quickly pull
your identity information
into Google Identity, enabling
you to make Cloud access
decisions based on group
memberships and user lists
that you already have.
That's key to
context-aware access.
Who you are matters and is more
important than where you are.
Without the who, we can't
make a good decision about
whether or not a given
request should be granted.
Our migration to this
BeyondCorp inspired
model requires knowledge about
identity for each request.
That's how Identity-Aware
Proxy can make
its person-based decisions.
Let's say you decide your
first order of business
is to lock down your financial
tools to just folks in finance
to reduce the chance of
revenue data leaking.
Your finance web
applications can
be protected by
Identity-Aware Proxy using
the identity groups you
brought into Google earlier.
It's quick and easy to
restrict your payroll
app to only people
in the finance group
with just a few clicks.
This system also lets you
automate updating access
when people change roles.
If I used to work in finance
then move over to legal,
my payroll management
access should disappear.
As soon as my groups are
updated within Google Identity,
IAP will enforce
the current policies
based on my new memberships.
Give it a try with one of the
various quick starts for IAP
or the guide for Cloud
Directory Sync linked below.
To get more detail,
check out my blog post
for step-by-step
instructions and subscribe
to get more videos on
context-aware access.
When it comes to protecting your
company, keep your data yours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]